[Música]
a primeira vez que eu vi um ted
eu pensei eu quero fazer isso olhei
pensei ainda vou fazer isso sem idéia do
que ia me trazer até aqui e quando o
convite chegou fiquei super animado de
ter mais um item na minha lista de
coisas que eu quero fazer é arriscado e
chegou a hora de definir sobre falar e
eu girei em torno disso durante semanas
até entender que o que me trouxe até
aqui foi a minha história
uma vez me perguntar se eu gostava de
natal eu falei que sim eu não achava
natal uma coisa ruim
só achava um pouco triste e aqui está
não é que a minha história seja
completamente triste mas tudo que me
transformou até hoje ou é resultado de
alguma coisa que deu errado ou de alguma
coisa que é de certa forma tristão por
isso talvez eu nunca tenha enxergado a
tristeza como algo que é só ruim uma
grande vantagem se uma criança
silenciada
eu nunca fui eu nunca fui uma criança e
petrus perdia pro lado eu sempre fui uma
criança introspectivo e eu tenho poucas
fotos de mim antes dos cinco anos talvez
umas 10 em nenhuma delas aparece
sorrindo e minha família a mãe fala que
eu não sorria porque eu já sabia que
viver é difícil e é uma grande vantagem
ser uma criança assim se torna expert em
observar pessoas e interpretar reações
isso é quase uma habilidade de
pensamento
então eu consigo saber se há alguma
coisa estranha em uma conversa por texto
ou de criança silenciada porque hoje eu
sei que não era timidez
claro que eu tenha de estar aqui exposta
o julgamento 100 pessoas mas não é
timidez
embora a minha família nunca tenha
acumulado posses
meu pai sempre fez questão de morar
perto do centro
então eu cresci num bom bairro porque
ele não queria depender de transporte
público
não estudei numa boa escola estadual
depois ganhou bolsa de estudos numa
escola particular com bolsa de estudo de
inglês
você estuda no cursinho e até morei come
com bolsa de estudo na universidade
federal e talvez por isso hoje eu acho
um pouco estranho pagar a conta
mas eu também sinto uma certa satisfação
em fazer isso não devia o dinheiro
embora mas saber que eu tenho o dinheiro
pra pagar as minhas contas e todas essas
bolsas estão relacionadas ao aprendizado
que meus pais talvez sem perceber e me
deixaram trancada não que com certeza
você vai receber tenham laços com alguém
que trago sim na maior parte da minha
adolescência
meus pais não tinham dinheiro mas eles
conheciam pessoas
minha mãe poderia dar aulas de
networking com base em empatia e ela
nunca foi a uma reunião minha na escola
mas todas as vezes que ela foi até a
escola é porque eu estava sofrendo
bullying e essa palavra não existia na
época pelo menos não aqui no brasil é
uma pena porque problema que não tem
nome não existe não tem por que buscar
solução para o problema que não existe
eu lembro que quando eu tinha uns oito
anos a professora pediu pra eu ir buscar
um copo de água pra ela e quando eu
voltei ela estava passando um sermão na
turma pelas situações que estava vivendo
dentro de sal e eu não entrei eu fiquei
do lado de fora esperando ela terminar
sem que me visse e ela terminou com nós
todos vamos morrer e virar pouco desde
então passou a incomodar muito ser o
assunto
uma coisa que me incomodava muito uma
frase que me incomodava muito era nós
estávamos falando de você
eu sou filha do meio de dois irmãos e eu
perdi as contas de quantas vezes eu ouvi
a minha mãe falar
vocês não são diferentes de ninguém tudo
que eles podem vocês podem
na época eu percebi que alguma coisa na
primeira frase contra dizia segundo e
vice versa mas eu não entendi o que hoje
eu sei que existe nós existe eles nós
éramos diferentes sim nossa não eram os
piores como queria que a gente acreditar
se seu irmão sempre gostamos de uma
certa boneca que era caríssima na época
então eu tinha uma ela tinha outra gente
tinha o marido de cada uma delas e as
nossas bonecos em todas as brincadeiras
sempre eram muito independentes e eram
executivas e o marido não tinha nem nome
não tinha profissão número que vem
escrito na caixinha e ninguém que
ensinou isso pra gente lá em casa mas eu
sou de uma família patriarcal
então eu cresci ouvindo as mulheres da
minha família dizendo que a gente não
deveria depender de homens me perdi um
pouco que um dia eu cismei que a gente
tinha que ter uma boneca daquela
diferente como agente ea minha mãe rodou
a cidade inteira nas lojas de brinquedo
mas o melhor que ela conseguiu foi uma
boneca de cabelo marrom e ela falava
aquela boneca era caríssimo
eu ainda tenho ela fala eu ganhei a
minha então com 10 anos eu estava
buscando por uma coisa que hoje também
tem nome representatividade
eu cheguei na adolescência eu me achava
a menina mais feia do mundo
eu ouvia piadinhas sobre a minha
aparência quando andava na rua
eu lembro de rezar perguntando pra deus
por que que eu não tinha me feito bonita
ao invés de inteligente eu vou estudar
numa escola particular e para irritar os
meninos da turma ele escrever o meu nome
junto
um deles no quadro dentro de um coração
e depois de um tempo aprende só a
levantar a pagar e sentar sem falar nada
aquilo me irritava muito pra eles era só
brincadeira
apesar disso eu sempre fui a única da
turma que conversava com todo mundo
eu podia escolher com qual grupo eu ia
merendar no recreio
o que é isso de não sentir pertencimento
tem uma vantagem c passa a circular por
vários grupos tentando se encontrar me
perdi de novo então eu aprendi a
conviver em lugares e entre pessoas que
às vezes eram o x comigo passada
adolescência veio vestibular e eu estava
determinado a entrar na universidade
federal de minas no curso de arquitetura
e urbanismo eu sempre soube que eu
queria fazer tudo bani zhu meu pai
chegava com o jornal e eu corria para
pegar o caderno de anúncios e ficava
horas em cima da das plantas dos imóveis
e e dos prédios e aí eu fiz o vestibular
e eu não passei só depende de mim eu não
passei e aqui ele trouxe o sofrimento
muito grande porque eu tinha um plano eu
cresci no interior é o meu plano era ir
para a capital estudar voltar pra casa
da minha mãe no fim de semana e
socializar o mínimo possível e deu
errado então no ano seguinte eu resolvi
que eu faria vestibular para duas
universidades e eu lembro disso até hoje
por quatro pontos eu não passei de novo
quatro pontos na segunda fase não passei
de novo na universidade federal de minas
mas eu era a primeira na lista de espera
da universidade federal de viçosa que
pra mim é a mesma coisa de não ter
passado não tinha glória está numa lista
de espera
e aí tudo que eu queria era que não me
cha
mas sim porque ficava às 6 horas de
distância da casa da minha mãe e eu não
ia conseguir executar meu plano mas me
chamaram e essa foi a primeira grande
virada na minha vida eu entrei e nos
primeiros três meses eu só conseguia
pensar em quando eu poderia pedir
transferência
depois de três meses eu percebi que não
é tão ruim assim
depois de um tempo eu percebi que
ninguém se importava muito se você era
alto magro obeso inteligente não tão
inteligente
as pessoas eram muito diferentes entre
si e todo mundo conversava muito em todo
mundo com todo mundo sobre qualquer
assunto porque não era uma opção 90% dos
alunos lá são de fora estão a
quilômetros de distância de casa depois
de um tempo eu percebi que dali sairiam
os melhores amigos que eu poderia ter na
vida e depois de cinco anos eu não seria
mesmo realmente são os melhores amigos
que eu tenho na vida a gente está
completando 10 anos de formado hoje e
ninguém acredita quando a gente se reúne
que aquela turma é a turma de faculdade
porque nós somos muito diferentes
é pouco provável que nós gostaríamos
amigos fora daquele contexto e de fato
nunca mais foi a mesma
eu aprendi a conviver bem com o defeito
dos outros e aí eu podia conviver bem
com defeito dos outros porque eu não
poderia conviver bem com os meus
aqueles que eu enxergava com defeito e
aqueles que a sociedade me apontava como
defeito e eu cheguei à conclusão de que
eu não precisava ser perfeita eu não
precisava ser completa
eu não precisava sorri sem querer só
porque as pessoas achavam que eu era
sério demais e eu não precisava deixar o
meu cabelo como as pessoas esperavam que
ele deveria estar
eu me formei e aí voltei para o interior
da cidade da minha mãe para trabalhar
com o projeto arquitetônico e eu
trabalhei com o projeto por seis anos
sou apaixonada por projeto arquitetônico
mas depois de um tempo aquilo parou de
fazer sentido pra mim meu trabalho não
tinha o poder de impactar a vida das
pessoas da forma que eu desejava
esperava eu trabalhava na maior parte do
tempo é com residências de alto padrão
eu tinha de forma freqüente na minha
cabeça uma frase que um tio meu me falou
pouco depois que me formei e fui conta
pra ele que eu trabalharia muito
elogiado
ele falou pra mim o bom pra você não é
suficiente
ele não quer dizer que eu merecia algo
melhor
ele quer dizer que eu teria que fazer
sempre muito melhor se eu quiser sair do
lugar
eu resolvi fazer um concurso público e
eu passei e essa foi a segunda grande
virada na minha vida eu fui morar em
belo horizonte
fui morar sozinha e eu fui trabalhar
numa instituição onde eu acreditava
muito que eu poderia e impactar a vida
de muita gente mas depois de um ano eu
percebi que eu não ia conseguir fazer
aquilo mas eu tinha tempo livre para
buscar a transformação fora dali
então comecei a procurar por coisas que
fizessem sentido pra mim
hoje eu sei que não é a gente encontre o
sentido às coisas que fazem sentido é
que encontra gente no intervalo muito
curto de tempo eu fui convidado a
conhecer uma jovem que tinha colocado
todo o dinheiro da sua formatura em uma
plataforma virtual para que as pessoas
pudessem forma gratuita trocar
habilidade e conhecimento depois se
conhecendo essa plataforma é o vídeo
madrugada uma mulher correndo gritando
aos prantos porque ela estava sendo
perseguida por um homem e uma padaria
abriu a porta para entrar e eu li na
internet um relato de violência sexual
que me deixou dormir muito mal e me fez
acordar com certeza de que algo deveria
ter sido feito para que alguém pudesse
ter estado lá por ela e por outros
mulheres porque elas pudessem ser livre
de realizar o sonho de mudar a vida de
alguém como aquela jovem que eu tinha
conhecido e não é porque não viu
impedimento para que eu fizesse alguma
coisa eu liguei para minha irmã logo
cedo e falei pra ela eu já sei o que eu
quero fazer
eu quero construir algo que seja maior
que eu me inscrevi num evento
pensei em um aplicativo pensei numa
história e fui pra esse evento sem
conhecer ninguém todo mundo era da área
de tecnologia bizness o design e eu
hesitei até o último segundo em subir no
palco para tentar convencer aquelas
pessoas de que eu tinha uma boa idéia e
eu convenci falando pra mim mesmo você
passou seis anos fazendo as pessoas
pagarem por suas idéias não sobe lá eu
subi com tem uma história e terminei com
sabe aquele pedido de quando chegar
avisa quem é que avisa que a gente não
chega
e essa foi a terceira grande virada na
minha vida que é amá la em nossos genes
como um aplicativo
fomos informados de que somos uma
startup
o que eu espero hoje aquela seja acima
de tudo um movimento
eu sou mulher negra a arquiteta e
urbanista empreendendo na área de
tecnologia
querendo combateu do silêncio mas o dc
dores que existe que a violência sexual
eu tô cinco vezes fora da casinha e eu
não precisei falar de gênero e cor para
que vocês entendessem tudo o que está
por trás de todas essas histórias que eu
contei aqui as pessoas ficam surpresas
de ver o ponto em que nós conseguimos
chegar com essa solução eu não sou da
área de tecnologia
o henrique que é meu sócio não
desenvolve aplicativos e sons só nós
dois
mesmo sem investimento
realmente o dinheiro é pouco a maior
parte sai do meu bolso
mas eu tenho um trunfo eu conheço
pessoas desde que tudo isso começou
eu ouvi cinco relatos pessoalmente ouvir
cinco relatos de ataques e tentativas de
estupro e estupro
e eu fui abraçada por incontáveis
mulheres que eu nunca vi logo eu a minha
e de cara fechada que não me fácil eu
tenho pra mim que se nada sair como
planejado porque claro que eu tenho um
sonho grande porque a gente está
construindo
mas se nada sair como planejado
a gente precisa garantir que está
deixando um rastro positivo
as pessoas não querem ouvir que a cada
11 minutos uma mulher é estuprada no
brasil é desconfortável não é cômodo
o que eu faço hoje não é confortável pra
mim também mas está tudo bem porque
incomodada é o meu status permanente
eu ouvi de uma mulher diferente como eu
uma frase que me faz pensar que se nada
sai como planejado ainda vai ter valido
a pena
ela falou pra mim
obrigada eu descobri que eu não posso
aceitar ser menos do que o melhor que eu
posso ser
isso mostra que você exatamente quem eu
sou e falar a verdade que as pessoas não
querem ouvir
é revolucionário desde que tudo isso
começou se eu disser que eu conheci 100
pessoas cerca de 80 delas estão
trabalhando
mudar processo mais ou menos 20 pessoas
enxergam diferente mas enxergar
diferente não é suficiente você precisa
fazer diferente e esse com cerca de 5 e
dessas pessoas eu gosto está perto esse
sim talvez eles não enriqueçam tão
rápido
talvez eles não saibam como que eles
fazem vai ver o dinheiro mas eles têm a
certeza de que o caminho é trabalhar
para mudar pessoas
a minha batalha pessoal é para que
meninas saibam que as mulheres têm um
poder transformador enorme nas mãos e
que quando elas resolvem agir
isso tem um impacto enorme em todo mundo
que está em volta delas o meu fim é a
segurança mas o meu meio é a liberdade
isso não é só sobre segurança é sobre a
liberdade de ir até ali a fazer o que
tem que ser feito para mudar o mundo e
voltar inteiro sozinha se for preciso eu
espero profundamente que o futuro seja
feminino
por que isso se traduza em um futuro
mais humano
obrigado
[Aplausos]